everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're in game 9
of our coverage the 2016 World Chess
Championship game it was pretty crazy we
had Sergei caveat him playing the black
pieces coming up with a win against
Magnus Carlsen so we only have four
games left madness Carson will play
white in game 10 and 12
Sergey caddie I can be playing the white
pieces in game 9 today and game 11 as
well if we actually need all those games
so we're going to get started with
Sergey karyakin playing the white pieces
pawn to e4 pawn e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop to b5 similar opening as he has
played before and some of these had been
pretty drawn I'm not sure that he cares
too much about drawing if he draws out
he's the new champion so Sergei karyakin
Bishop to b5 pawn a6 bishop back here to
a4 Knight f6 castle on the kingside pawn
to b5 Bishop to b3 and the Magnus
Carlsen is the first one to kind of
change things up he recognizes that if
he wants a victory and even at the black
pieces Magnus Carlsen definitely has the
opportunity to win if he can find some
pretty creative opening lines he needs
to play something different and that's
exactly what he does he goes more of the
good as defense which Bishop to c5 so
not something we see all that common
pawn to d6 Bishop to e7 castling on the
King side is what we've been seeing most
of the tournament Bishop to c5 me
immediately getting that dark square
bishop involvement to the center of the
board that's what he goes for pawn to a4
trying to strike this pawn defense over
here on the Queen side of the board and
then rook to b8 he had some different
options he could have played pawn to b4
immediately trying to break somebody up
these pawns let's say pawn here to c3
pawn takes on c3 could recapture with
this pawn could take with this knight
but I think this is kind of the approach
he once he could then play rook over
here to b8 has a semi-open file to start
attack castle on the King side has
double bishop pair can really start to
open up the board and start to attack
his opponent but decides to go ahead and
play rook here to be 8 and then pawn up
to c3 and now it's too late to play pawn
to b4 because after
pawn to b4 then all of a sudden pawn up
d4 if we do see the exchange on board
Bishop comes back here to e7 since it
was being attacked and then I'll Knight
to g5 is just it's catastrophic for
Magnus Carlsen he can't really come back
from that with the bishop attacking here
on f7 forcing the ponds up here all in
all this is gonna be extremely bad so he
didn't go down this line he decided this
position to play pawn here to c6 d6
solidifying this pawn chain getting
ready to castle on the kingside Pondy
for the bishop comes back could have
exchanged if he wanted to on d4 but
decides to go and hold on to that double
bishop pair knowing that he needs all
the material really he can to have some
sort of big attack later on have a
chance for victory in this game pawn
takes on to b5 pawn recaptures and then
after Knight 8 3 magnus carlsen really
has to decide if he wants to try to hold
on to this pawn or castle on the King
side and then start for an attack on the
Kings side of the board
Magnus decides to go ahead and castle on
the Kings side and then after the Knight
takes on b5 after giving up material
Bishop down here to g4 pinning down this
Knights the bishop comes to a c2
protecting this pawn recognized
recognized in Magnus Carlsen starting to
attack a lot on the Kings side of the
board pawn takes d4 after that comes
back would you see another exchange and
then the bishop takes on g3 and this
kind of sets up the pond to capture
doesn't want to recapture with this
Queen here because then the bishop comes
down takes on d4 really controlling the
center of the board so this is kind of
madness Carson's plan he says there's an
opening on the Kings side you don't have
protection in front of your King so I'm
gonna start to really attack that circle
yeah Kenny he has a pretty solid
position here after Knight to h5 that
actually was played King here to h1 he
can bring his rook to g1 if you ever
played against us it does get kind of
tricky while you don't have a lot of
defense in front of your king
you also can really start to put
pressure on your opponent because you're
attacking their King side of the board
you have double bishop pears for white
that's very dangerous you have double
Brooks you can double barrel get your
other work involved into the this.g file
so really start to put pressure so both
sides are somewhat vulnerable to a
strong attack
either side of the board so both sides
have to be very careful on board but all
know I definitely choose cardiac
incision he is up a pawn and material
double bishop pair on a fairly open
board I think he has a pretty strong
attack here Queen here to f6 Bishop to
e6 adding another defender on this
square and the stern of the board here
on d4 pawn to c5 pawn up here to a5 and
the way you see some exchange on boards
and I think Magnus Carlsen actually ends
up pretty well in this exchange because
he essentially sticks circular County a
came with some isolated pawn so before
with this pawn on e4
you know his pawn structure even though
double pawns on the F file they were
kind of connected in the center that's
pretty good but after they exchanged
White's up upon in material but this
pawns don't really played nicely with
each other so cardiac can double bishop
here but I think Magnus Carlsen did well
that's a kind of maneuver out of that
surrogate caddie I can place rook up
here to a6 pinning down this bishop to
the Queen so you know why suddenly good
job of continuously putting pressure on
his opponent not staying back and
playing defensive he could as we talked
about just draw the rest of this
tournament in win and so far we've seen
him play pretty defensive all throughout
the tournament even his white pieces
we've seen more passive moves and very
aggressive move so you can see in this
one he's even though Magnus Carlsen came
out with that Goss defense getting his
bishop involved cardiac and has not
backed down he seems to be prepared for
this long theoretical opening that we
have and seems to be playing extremely
well and more aggressive than even I was
expecting so we're over here to d8 just
trying to get it more involvement to the
Syrian the board wasn't really doing too
much on f8 and then work over here to g1
so it starts to attack the semi open
file as we talked about and just kind of
builds the the pressure on Magnus
Carlsen to defend lots of things he has
to worry over here he does have this
past pawn in the center of the board and
then now he has this rook over here on
g1 Carlsen with Queen to d7 rook up here
to g4 getting ready to protect this
square but also you could swing it over
here to h4 start to have more pressure
eventually he could swing his rook to
dg1 add double works here on this King
side the board really starts to add
pressure to magnus carlsen Knight to f6
kind of forcing the rook but that's kind
of think we're cardiac and wanted to go
rook over here to h4 Queen down here b5
attacking the rook rook just swings back
here to a-1 pawn to g6 and the rook here
to b1 this does open up for the bishop
to come here to f7 sacrifice check you
know and that would have a discovered
attack on the Queen here on b5 so -
house immediately played Queen to d7 and
then Queen up to d3 still protecting a
lot of the same material the Queen was
before but it does allow them to get a
little bit more aggressive if he wants
to attack some of the squares Queen here
to see for putting pressure on f7 a
little bit later on if he wants to can
easily get involved attack on the King
side of the board if he wants to be
fairly aggressive so just opens up the
door for some options Knight here to d5
and then rook to g1 so cardiac can
starts to add pressure on the Kings at
the board with his rooks but this this
move from man is costing the knight on
d5 although this Knights not on an
outpost it is doing a lot of things that
he wants to be doing it is fairly well
protected Kari Atkins probably not gonna
be looking to give up his double Bishop
pair right here but this night does stop
this LightSquared bishop the
LightSquared Bishop is aimed at this
square here on f7 which is kind of a
weakness for Magnus crossing with so
much pressure building up on the side of
the board but also stops this past pawn
here on d4 from pushing up so that's
exactly what Madison is looking to do he
has to play somewhat defensive right now
recognizing the his opponent has a
stronger setup as far as an attack does
have the double bishop pair the double
row cover here on the King side but
doing a good job and I think this night
here on d5 allows him to play just the
correct defence that he's trying to call
him from here plays Bishop back here to
c7
Bishop here to g5 attacking the rook
rook is forced to come over here to e8
controlling the the e-file so that's
always good Queen to c4 and then rook
down here to be 5 and then Queen back to
c2 and if you watch the press conference
this was one of those moves were kind of
yackin that they always look at lots of
positions and just get each player's
take as far as the opening in the middle
game and
in game how it ended they did they just
want to see what each of the players was
thinking this position specifically
karyakin said he had a little hope and
the little hope was after the Queen
comes down here to see to he wanted his
opponent to play Knight to b4 okay this
is a discovered attack on this Bishop
now the rook is protecting it here but
opens up the door for four more attacks
on board and it does attack this Queen
here on c2 so cardiac and would have to
respond now what magnus carlsen probably
saw him what Kuryakin was hoping for is
that he could play Queen to c6 and this
would be a devastating take magnus
carlsen would have to respond to this
because Queen here to h7 that starts to
get extremely bent so you can imagine
but after the pawn takes here on g6 then
Bishop to f6 and there's no way to stop
a mate threat with just rook up here to
AJ now you can kind of delay the
inevitable with rook to h5 but we just
have to take here because this rook here
on g1 it's kind of stopping this pawn
from taking right here so there's no way
to really stop it Queen down here to h3
delays the inevitable but at the end of
the day rook up here to AJ it would have
been checkmate so that's what cardiac
him was hoping for that would have been
pretty epic if this game ended like that
Magnus Carlsen is not having any of it
my name is sure if he ever thought about
moving his knight which is so crucial in
the center of the board
but cardiac and Lise was hoping for that
we're cover here - a8 Bishop to c4 and
then we have a rook to a5 kind of
double-barreling but doesn't want to get
out of the way of the bishop attacking
it bishop down here d2 just continues to
put pressure on his opponent attacking
the rook where comes here to a5
attacking and the bishop Queen to d3
centralizing protecting that Bishop rook
down here to Avon decides to go ahead
and exchange and then King here to g2
and then Knight to e7 this was kind of
the the highest point in the game if see
what Magnus Carlsen is trying to do he
has a decision to make he wants to start
to get his knife
involved to the kingside the board
because he does see a lot of the
pressure building up but there's kind of
this this weird transition where he
wants to bring his Knight to f5 that's
kind of the dream square it's nice
little outpost move for him can stop a
lot of the critical squares that cardiac
ins trying to build pressure on but in
between here
cardiac in has a decision he has to two
moves that he can really play and
afterward he said he looked at both of
them in this position they're moved 39
and once you get to move 40 you do get
additional time and he used 25 minutes
so essentially all of his time he had
left on this movement I had two
positions or two options he could take
here on f7 in exchange that will kind of
go over the variations he also played
had the option of playing Queen here to
b3 just sending up an attack and Bishop
taking on f7 now in the game he decided
to go ahead and play Bishop takes on f7
and you know everyone on social media
and at the press conference was kind of
like hey we did not expect you to play
Bishop to f7 mostly because he's played
pretty defensively he hasn't been super
aggressive with any crazy you know
tactical sacrifices or variations that
are just really complex he tries to be
you know pretty composed not to get any
trouble and just not making any mistakes
so Bishop to f7 not what everyone was
expecting that's what he played after
the king takes here on f7 Queen to c4
check essentially forcing his opponent
to come to g7 needs to protect the
square here on age 7
so King here to g7 is what Magnus
Carlsen played if he try something else
let's say King to e8 it all falls apart
after the rook takes on it h7 so cannot
allow that to happen
so he does side correctly play King here
to g7 and then pawn up to d5 threatening
the bishop to see c3 check which would
fork the King get this rook here on a1
starting to get some of that material
back since he did sacrifice a bishop now
rook or black would really like to play
rook here to d1 like getting out of the
harm's way but then after the bishop
here to h6 this is very difficult we see
the King come
to age six Bishop e2 g5 giving up
material but really just wants to play
rook up here to h7 that's just so
dangerous Queen down here to a d5 check
we could see the Queen come up here to
e7 and this is just really threatening
the rook here to f7 so maybe I could
also take the bishop depending on where
the bishop moves to but let's say Bishop
to d8 of a novel sudden to rook to f7
check no kind of way around this the
Queen has to come here take on f7 and
then all of a sudden this would be a
very losing proposition for Magnus
Carlsen Queen better than a Brooke and a
bishop and then three pawns to one that
would be extremely bad so as we come
back after the bishop takes and the King
takes there is no way to stop this so
instead of playing we work over here to
d1 the knight comes to f5 and this is
kind of squared that Magnus Carlsen
wanted to come to all along I'm not sure
he wanted to come to at this position
you probably wanted to do it a little
bit earlier but Bishop to c3 check
forcing the trade of the rook here on a1
and of recovery here on h4 Queen takes
on h4 and then the Queen takes on d5 now
in this position if we kind of look at
it the surrogate karyakin is up a pawn
and material but all the commentators
kind of looked at and said if you come
back here instead of taking with the
bishop on f7 if he were to have played a
Queen to b3 he probably would have ended
up winning and even after him Magnus
Carlsen saw Bishop to f7 Magnus Carlsen
getting ready to to get to move forward
he looked at this position and he kind
of had this look on his face of well I
kind of dodged a bullet there things
could have gone a lot worse for me so
although we did see an amazing sacrifice
from Circular karyakin but the end of
the day not completely sure that it was
the best move and he did recognize that
at the at the end of this game because
this this ending is very very difficult
for anyone to turn into a win now I'm
not sure in this position a Sergey Caddy
I can count looked at and said you know
hey I had such a strong attack
I had lots of opportunities and then
essentially almost had a coin flip of
finding the right move and maybe if he
had a few more minutes he may have
played Queen to b3 I think they could
have drawled in any position matters
cause even playing Queen back here to f7
says let's just go dictate to Queens the
game is over let's go on to you know
game number 10 where I'm gonna have the
white pieces kuryakin decided to play on
you can see that they kind of moved
their pieces around for another few
hours no side really made any advance in
the game for the most part they didn't
even move there their pawns too much
every now and then they'd moved just a
little bit but no side could really
breakthrough in the game there was
there's just no way with bishops on the
same Square and in the Queen's and
Magnus Carlsen essentially just trying
to trade off for car yeah can't do
anything besides draw this game so at
the end of this it was a six hour
marathon and after what probably could
have been a draw they played for another
three hours and then after this position
the bishop comes here to f6 karyakin
decides okay this could just go on
forever and no one's no one's doing any
improvement so they decide to draw this
game but I said kudos to cardiac and you
know after the big win with the black
pieces I really expected almost a fast
draw in this game which I think he could
have easily done but he came out a very
very nice preparation with Magnus
Carlsen played kind of an odd defense he
still was very aggressive
I didn't let Magnus Carlsen take the
initiative at all and at the end he
essentially had a coin flip to maybe win
I think it would have been difficult to
win with Queen to b3 but a lot of people
are saying he had much better lines that
he could have taken put Magnus Carlsen
in a tough spot Magnus Carlsen said you
know this was a marathon and Queen to b3
would have been much more difficult so
Madison seemed excited that he came out
with a drawl and he does have white for
two of the last three games so although
we will be playing the rest of the games
game 12 there's not really a scenario
even if I guess car yeah Kanka win the
next two we will
have game 12th in but for the most part
we'll probably playing all 12 games
Magnus Carlsen
it may come down to the very last game
if we do have a kind of tie in points
then we have will have a tiebreaker so
the last game game 12 is on November
28th they would take a day off and then
come back for the tie Burke and they
would play some quick chests some
15-minute 5-minute chest and at the end
of that they play Armageddon which we'll
get into if that time arrives but
hopefully you guys enjoy this game now
the last few games definitely been
pretty exciting much more so than
they'll say the first six games in the
tournament so definitely enjoyable
looking for some crazy fireworks in game
10 is madness Carlson has the white
pieces and know that he really has to
come out with a win does not want to put
it all on game 12 because then Kari
Atkins gonna be in the draw mood that
you you haven't seen from anyone before
so game Tim he really needs to make
something happen but they guess watching
I'll see y'all in game Tim